india's biggest ever ipo launches today
with fintech company paytm looking to
raise almost two and a half billion
dollars the company has more than 300
million registered customers and a 40
share in mobile transactions making it
one of india's largest internet
companies the digital payment platform
is backed by chinese conglomerate
alibaba japan's softbank and warren
buffett's berkshire headway the three
shareholders combined own around one
third
of pay tm
all right let's get more on this we're
from charo kartikeya dw correspondent in
delhi charity good to have you on the
program paytm is looking to raise two
and a half billion dollars what does
make the company so valuable
hi chris it's good to speak to you and
as you rightly introduced the customer
base and that is precisely the big
reason why this ipo is so big paytm is i
feel so big is because of its large
customer base you know uh when paytm
launched a couple of years ago more than
a couple of years ago its subscriber
base was small
a lot of people were not used to digital
payments but these days when you move
around uh in uh
in in market areas uh in cities as well
as in villages in small towns paytm is
everywhere even
street side hawkers and vendors
everybody has a paytm qr code so it's
subscriber best base has
really gone up uh the number of
transactions is also very high so these
are uh the reasons that make it such a
such an attractive ipo now retail
business in india traditionally has been
dominated by cash transactions now you
mentioned paytm is everywhere how was
the company able to change this
traditional way of doing business
so uh i think chris the reason is uh
paytm happened to be in the right place
at the right time it has been in the
indian market for quite some time now
but two events in the recent past gave
it the sort of uh push that has uh
brought the company to the position
where it is right now one of them that
was a demonetization that was uh
initiated by
india's prime minister narendra modi now
demonet the currency notes of 500 and
1000 for the largest number of notes in
terms of circulation those notes were
demonetized and at that point of time
the
federal government started giving a new
kind of push
to digital transactions paytm already
happened to be around at that time and
that's when digital payments really took
off uh even then the digital
transactions were
a little slow to begin with but then the
pandemic has really given it the kind of
push that uh people possible that cash
trans digital transactions possibly
needed two years back the rate of growth
of paytm was a little bit slow but then
in during these pandemic years in 2020
and 2021
every shop owner every street hawker
vendor almost has a paytm qr code and
probably that's the reason how the
nature of shopping has changed in india
let's look at the bigger picture here i
mean this year india has seen a record
number of unicorns created startups with
a valuation of one billion dollars or
more what is behind that
i think a couple of reasons uh could be
uh
held responsible for that chris one is
it shows that people have uh there's a
demand for new stocks among those who
are interested in buying stocks and
these new stocks appear to be mostly uh
in in the internet-based economy so more
than 30
startups have have become unicorns there
are several more in the pipeline and
startups that are essentially running on
vc funding uh and before they're before
their ipos they did not have any profits
to show on the book it's only the fact
that they were trying to bring down
their losses these kind of ipos these
kind of companies are uh
launching ipos and making it big this
shows that there's a lot of appetite for
new stocks
tariq kartikeya filling us in on the ipo
of paytm today charu thank you
thank you chris